aha welcome to this video playing cards
and yeah yeah tricky tricky handle so
first moose were already clear let's see
what I can do now okay maybe again
attack that with c5 and this should be
quite nice when winning some time there
on the night okay check here let's get
some play down a checking beetle I'm
threatening to take that with the rook
not with the bishop I take it with the
bishop okay not not going to happen yo
so Queen B 6 or not maybe do that it's
bishop asics something at this kind of
very crude attack on the pond if I go
Queen to deform how is he covering the
pawn and I know that looks extremely
crude but if it's okay it's a pawn maybe
I can take that I normally don't do that
I don't like to to grab early pawns for
some giving the opponent big
compensation but but why not experiment
a little bit so he wants to keep it at
least for the time being but okay if I
go rook before for loop c4 or Quincy
fall for that matter August basics
that's also certainly on let's go Bishop
a sex
shouldn't forget that b3 is just not on
hmm that's not quite sure what you
should do it looks look slightly
uncomfortable Bishop e3 Quincy for
Quincy for Bishop c4 Bishop 87 that
looks very weird I have at least rook
before at the end of that line Oh bit
uncomfortable that strange Queen the
form of us may be quite good I am sure
it looks very weird so I'm skeptical but
at the moment I don't see what he should
do we should f-4s maybe mms but still i
can go look before
yeah 11 advantage of that slightly
offbeat opening really is openings that
really is if you know what you're doing
there let's say sometimes the lack in
quality can be compensated by by
knowledge and and not knowledge of
familiar ideas and themes and I think
this is the Emporium um pretty typical
case of that I mean not that I know it
too well but it feels like he doesn't
feel at home here and the setup at least
them is very difficult for why to claim
and he spent some gay spending a huge
amount of time iam so at least here it's
easy to enflame I move have to take c4
go from go from them yeah and Bishop a
Sapna that is this the idea
Bishop e7 rook e8 night to be 6 rook a
794 d5 as a good line
ok I think that's good run locate does
he have anything else you can go look
see one but happy should be five then
nine wait Brooke a roxy one should be
five should work I was a bit skeptical
on my back rangas week so there might be
some some tactics but after Luke see one
Bishop be 593 I can take the knight on
c3 was check and then the bishop on sm
yeah so Bishop to b5 huh which is a
double attack essentially a seven and a
four
damn that should lose a piece unless I'm
overlooking something
that's a piece plus the time I mean
white resins Jim it was surprisingly
difficult maybe Queen d4 was good I mean
it looks strange but what is he doing
after it just the text form ok computer
wants to play Queen to a form it's not
the most natural move ever of course you
can ok you can castle let's that's true
we can maybe just play at form for
compensation this is maybe the the right
way to do it and yeah just ask black is
it ok that you moved your queen all the
time like here here here that that's
that's certainly an interesting way to
do it now that's not easy now my rook
here is hanging and something like d6
it's very weakening yeah that's the way
to go that looks dangerous for black
maybe maybe interest a queen move that
that makes get this into the position
our white has excellent compensation in
this kind of position but this is I
don't know I really don't see a very
good to reply after that he spent more
than two minutes in this position I
think he just loses the pawn it has to
kind of fish for compensation and I
don't know if there is something comp is
on minus 0.4 something like that that
yeah and Bishop a seven-hour losses but
he has no move now it just really a me
the pawn down and it's a big pond it's
an Center related porn yeah this this is
just losing immediately another key line
was this this and d5 that's that's it I
interesting actually this is an honey
move pointed out by the comp and I
cannot take the night but I can take the
pawn which is good enough you know and I
go lucky six and 297 yeah like wins yeah
interesting I the kingside fianchetto is
sometimes an interesting weapon because
of the early early pressure here by the
way this is not necessary maybe maybe
maybe you can cancel it's always
interesting this is a trick that should
be remembered double attacking but this
is a more and that takes takes this is
this and black has one upon know it's
interesting interesting trick I don't
know it is because if this is enough
compensation for wide so you can argue
that maybe it's not necessary to play a
Quincy to maybe some other move Knight
c3 awesome okay well thanks for watching